you were just racking up the awards left
and right this minute too many where are
you gonna put them on this one uh the
tweener will go either uh I call it the
tweener I think do they do they all call
it the tweener yeah it'll go in the uh
either in the office I gotta get an
office now or uh I got our oh maybe
we'll hide it under the bed just in case
the robbers come oh my God
technician mean to you this evening oh
man I I don't even know it's just a
great great been a great weekend A lot
of my friends are here a lot of all my
family flew in hanging out it makes
everyone happy makes my wife help put it
all together my mom's so excited and my
sisters are so excited my kids are
pretty excited you know they I don't
think they realize what was going on
until last night they were in the room
watching all the comedians make make a
fool out of me and they were like oh
okay I do like this do they write an
acceptance speech for Dad tonight
because they did to the doctor Awards we
pulled the pen after that one going
overboard was your film debut yes 22
years old
it's a young spry Adam Sandler many a
times too yeah I was in afraid that was
probably the last time I was excited
about the shirt coming off when you
think back to that film what memories
come to mind and what would you tell
Young Adam Sandler when he was
auditioning for that movie wow I'd say
this is great great times are ahead I
got to meet Milton burrow during that
movie uh it was
that was a dream come true I went out
that's what I my I was trying to do
become an actor and a comedian and all
of a sudden I was in a movie and I was
playing a comedian and I I didn't care
about too much else in the world I was
just excited about going after it look
at you now yep things did we did good
you did you did very very well Adam I
caught up with Drew Barrymore you guys
are just Dynamic on screen and a couple
times now reminded her we're about
hitting that 10-year Mark for you guys
to collaborate again so she said you're
you know the ideas are percolating
they're Brewing we just said it this
morning to each other I saw her in a
hotel and her beautiful children and she
is
she's just so nice so nice to my family
always sits down hangs out with them the
best the best and when we when we make a
movie together every day is beautiful so
what's the next plot how are you oh yeah
we don't know yet we'll figure something
out let's get it going sometime fair
enough okay 25th anniversary The Wedding
Singer it is here what do you remember
most about being on that set yeah
memories I just remember remember
man I remember uh
just every day was exciting I remember
one night I wrestled the director we
wrestled that was fun it was it was just
a burst of energy I got and I think I
tackled them and and then he tackled me
back and and we I remember that
youngster
hey you look cute
yeah yeah you look handsome that way to
step it up is it were we supposed to
wear that yes how come I didn't get that
where did Judge all right sorry the
voice it always gets yeah me too but
speaking of a lot of your SNL brothers
are here tonight Rob Schneider Dana
carve he's actually yes yeah how is it
that you guys have stayed so close after
all these years why is that important to
love love those guys and we we feel we
back each other up we care about each
other we we think
I mean I think they're the funniest guys
I know so I just I'm very relaxed with
those guys
thank you so much for your time all
right good to see you
[Music]
foreign